okay so we've got McDonald's tweeting
these conspiracy theories about about
you know some sort of imaginary epidemic
of anti-trans hate crimes in fact nearly
all of the largest and richest
corporations in America are spreading
the utterly false talking points of BLM
Colin Kaepernick has been able to parlay
his supposed at oppression into
multi-million dollar deals with three
major corporations Disney Nike and
Netflix Vanity Fair has an article
calling cap a burgeoning media mogul
this is oppression this is what
oppression looks like in America you can
turn your oppression into a into a media
franchise worth millions of dollars then
if that's the case I mean God let me let
me be oppressed please I pray for that
kind of oppression meanwhile we've got
leftist inventing hate crimes
fabricating them nearly every week is
another example people are so desperate
to be actually oppressed that they're
they're just making it up as we talked
about yesterday a bunch of college
students are now claiming that they're
that they're traumatized they are so
traumatized by a joke that some kid
tweeted about George Floyd that they
can't go back to school a tweet a tweet
is now is now latched on to desperately
as an example of oppression people are
so desperate for oppression that that to
white people who painted over a mural of
black lives matter which is just just on
the street there was really City
sanctioned graffiti with black lives
matter written across the street and big
bold letters well two white people came
and painted over it they're being
charged with a hate crime for doing that
for painting over letters so if we can't
find actual white racist oppressors out
there killing black people then let's
like let's make these two white people
painting
some words on the on the street into our
racist oppressors why not or let's make
a garage door pull into a hate crime why
not oh but the black man who pummeled
the white Macy's employee that's not a
hate crime
or the black man who knocked over a 92
year old white woman and she hit her
head on a fire hydrant that's not a hate
crime or the black men who beat a white
woman with two by fours in New York
that's not a hate crime
yes but the white folks with paint who
painted over letters on the streets
committed a hate crime oh but the
Vandals who are literally burning
buildings and tearing down priceless
works of art those aren't hate crimes
either but this is you see that's how it
works the whole thing is a farce this
oppression is imaginary hallucinatory
it's not real it's not happening there
is no crisis towns and states across the
country are declaring racism a public
health crisis it's not the only crisis
is the one that left is protestors and
the media and Democrats are inventing
creating we are right now witnessing
something that is that is probably
unprecedented in the history of the
world a bunch of people who live lives
of freedom and liberty and and and
relative comfort and luxury are choosing
to destroy their country because they've
convinced themselves that they're the
victims of a completely imaginary
oppression it's as though our society
got bored with with with its own success
and decided to eat itself for fun here's
the reality unless you live
in the inner city of Chicago or a city
like that you are safer richer more
comfortable more secure and freer than
almost everyone who has ever lived
anywhere at any point anywhere in the
world you are in the top top top 1% if
not if not even if not in even more
exclusive company than that and in fact
even in the inner city you are wealthy
compared to a great portion of the
world's population you may not be very
safe but the danger you face is almost
entirely from within your own community
from criminals and drug dealers and
murderers within your community it's not
from racist agents of the state going
around randomly killing people because
they're not doing that but of course
it's doubtful that that most of the
protesters and people tearing down
statues and everything actually live in
the inner city many of them are
relatively affluent living lives of -
most people in the world unimaginable
ease and comfort in fact lives that are
so easy and comfortable that they can
somehow afford to spend days on end
protesting and they still have food to
eat and a roof over their head to come
home to the students at k-state who are
traumatized over over the tweet actually
had the time and energy and luxury to
protest over it watch this they're
marching through the streets Oh for a
tweet that they didn't like imagine
having that kind of luxury
one student mentioned in the Kansas City
comm article Mike Heller Ross has an
internship at ExxonMobil ok and and but
she had trouble at her internship
because she was so traumatized by the
tweet Exxon Mobil one of the most again
one of the most powerful corporations on
earth she has an internship there she
goes
major American University and thus just
based on those two things she's in a
better position and lined up for more
financial and professional success than
literally billions of other people on
earth and yet she says she's oppressed
because of a tweet it makes her scared
she lives in fear now because of the
tweet so how is this all happening why
are a bunch of spoiled brats who have
been given everything and who have never
been oppressed in their lives
nonetheless trying to burn the country
to the ground why are they going around
screaming about imaginary monsters why
are we watching our society
self-destruct at a moment in history
when it has achieved unprecedented
wealth luxury and liberty well we could
spend you know twelve hours or so
dissecting this I'm not gonna spend 12
hours but I do want to dissect it and
try to answer that question and we will
do that in just a second this video is
sponsored by blink sale the
revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description